The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, good afternoon.
So today we're going to
talk about learning.
So what can you do now that you
couldn't do as an infant,
very simply?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Talk, that's
a good one.
Language, that's pretty
good, right?
Anything else that you
couldn't do, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we don't
actually know what the
internal mental life of
an infant's like.
But it doesn't seem like they
remember many very specific
things about their lives.
You do.
But you know it's a lot more
than, you know a ton of stuff,
a lot of facts, right, things
about the world, the values
you hold, about your family,
your culture, the country or
countries you've grown up in.
You just know a ton compared
to an infant.
And there's only two ways
that you know this.
It's either in your genes when
you're born or you learned it
through life.
And so we're going to talk today
about how scientific
psychology tries to
approach learning.
And in a remarkable thing about
learning is we often
think, well, we're learning
lessons or whatever.
We're learning material.
But the important part of
learning the way we think
about it is that it allows us
to predict the future on the
basis of the past, right?
We want to learn lessons in life
to know what's desirable,
what's dangerous, what's a
smart way to do things so
we're more effective.
We choose what we want to do
better in the future to learn
from the past and predict
the future.
It imbues our word
with meaning.
For an infant, not much
means much, right?
They just look around.
Who knows what anything means.
Words, gestures, facial
expressions, there's not much
meaning of the world
out there.
For you, the world is full of
meaning, history, social
interactions, everything that
you're thinking about.
So how do we acquire the
meanings of things in the
world that matter to us?
And it's also had an interesting
kind of a give and
take with how we learn about
learning in scientific
psychology and sort
of historically.
I'll just touch a tiny
bit on that.
And we'll talk about three
aspects of learning today:
classical conditioning, operant
conditioning, and then
various ways in which there are
limits to conditioning.
Thank you, Todd.
So let's start with sort of one
of the most famous figures
in all of conditioning or
learning, Ivan Pavlov, who
actually won a Nobel Prize,
not for his studies of
learning, but for his sort of
groundbreaking studies for the
reflexes of digestion.
He worked out a lot of the
fundamentals of how, in
mammals, your stomach breaks
down food and that how food in
the mouth provokes specific
salivation that begins the
process by which food is
decomposed and then digested
in your stomach, the
fundamentals of really how we
live, right, eat to live.
And he was very interested in
salivation reflexes, what is
it that drives that first bit of
breaking down food in your
mouth with saliva?
And Pavlov was a pretty intense
researcher, as you
might be used to at MIT.
There's a famous story where a
graduate student came somewhat
late to the lab and said,
but Professor, there's a
revolution going on with
shooting in the streets.
This is in Russia.
And he said, what difference
does it make when you've got
work to do in the laboratory?
Next time there's a revolution,
get up earlier; so
anyway, not an easygoing
supervisor.
He would do experiments a little
rough in dogs, like cut
the esophagus, the path by which
food goes from the mouth
to the stomach, to understand
the role of the esophagus.
And he found that, even in those
animals, when he placed
food in the dog's mouth, he
expected, as a fundamental
biologist studying how digestion
works, that nothing
would happen.
But he noticed not only would
the dog salivate, even though
the food will never make it to
the stomach, but furthermore
the stomach juices, the gastric
juices that break down
food, also were released within
the stomach even though
the food would never
get there.
And then he got interested in
how it is that these things
are driven if they're not driven
simply as a direct
response to the arrival
of the food.
How is it that the mere sight
of the food or the sight of
the person bringing the food
would drive the salivation and
what he called psychic
secretions?
Because he was a biologist.
So he expected, basically, you
put the food in the mouth.
There's some chemistry between
the food and salivation.
And here he's finding, just
seeing food, just seeing the
person who would bring the
food, was driving these
fundamental biological
functions.
So there's a kind of experiment
that he would set
up where the dog
would be there.
And he would be measuring the
amount of salivation in some
way or another.
And in these kinds of
experiments-- and I'll go
through this language
a couple times--
in conditioning they've come up
with a sort of vocabulary
to describe the pieces of things
that go into this kind
of learning.
So there's an unconditioned
stimulus, which is food.
I mean you start with that.
You want to eat food.
And there's an unconditioned
response, which is you
salivate when you see the food
or if it's in your mouth.
That's the beginning.
Then you're going to add
what's initially
a meaningless stimulus.
In this case, it could
be anything.
But in this case, we'll
say it's a bell.
You ring a bell before
the food comes.
And you're going to get to
a conditioned response.
The animal will say, well, the
bell predicts the food.
And I'll salivate to
the bell itself.
Even though I'll never eat the
bell, I learned that it
predicts the food is coming.
And so you've created
a new association.
You learned something new about
the world, that a bell
signals something that
drives salivation.
So the two things are sort of
occurring next to each other
in time or what Aristotle talked
about as the law of
contiguity.
The animal learns that the bell
predicts the food coming.
And so here's the basic idea.
At first, the tone does not
drive salivation, right?
There's no reason to salivate
when you hear tone by itself.
But as the animal discovers
that the tone predicts the
food, the tone predicts the
food, then all of a sudden the
animal starts to learn that
simply the tone alone will
drive the salivation.
Now this stimulus
is conditioned.
And you have a conditioned
response that wasn't there to
start with.
It's very simple, right?
You learn the two
are associated.
And now you begin to have a
biological response to the
tone alone.
And typically what happens is
here's a learning curve.
Here's how often perhaps
you salivate.
And across trials you learn
more and more of that.
And you finally plateau at some
level of performance.
So a neat thing about Pavlov is,
although there weren't a
lot of movies at his time, there
is a little bit of film
of him and his actual dogs.
So here's Pavlov's
actual dogs.
So we said conditioning is
going to do two magical
things, right?
It's going to let us predict
the future on the
basis of the past.
And it is a very simple
experiment.
Now the bell predicts the food
coming up and the salivation.
And it imbues the world
with meaning.
In a sense, the bell now means,
here's dinner, right?
The bell is not just a bell.
It's something with meaning
and significance.
These are another example of
classical conditioning.
And it's got some sophisticated
properties.
You could go, well, balloons
popping water in your face,
food for dinner, that's
pretty basic stuff.
But here are some sophisticated
properties of
these as learning mechanisms.
So one was already talked about,
extinction, that, if
the bell continues to ring and
no food arrives, the learning
gets weakened, weakened,
and disappears.
So you can learn something.
And you can unlearn something
because it's no longer an
effective predictor
of the future.
Generalization is kind
of cued also.
So imagine the frequency of the
stimulus is this, just the
specific frequency
of the tone.
Well, if the tone is a little
bit different, you might still
think food is coming, right?
So it's not that you learn
the precise thing.
You'll still respond if it's
a pretty similar tone.
And as the tone gets more and
more different, the response
gets weaker and weaker, right?
So that's smart generalization.
I stay pretty close
to the tone.
I go for it.
I get further away,
eh, not so sure.
It's not all or none.
It's reasonably graded and
sensitive to the specifics of
the situation.
There's also one fascinating
thing, which is your acquired
conditioned response is
extinguished because you're
only hearing the bell and
there's no more food coming.
But when you come back in, you
often have a kind of preserved
recovery function of that CS.
It's like it's lurking
in you somewhere.
It's like I have a mental note
that this bell might mean
food, even though it
was extinguished.
It's still pretty interesting
stimulus.
So you'd have some easily
spontaneous recovery of these
kinds of learned conditioning.
It can also be sophisticated
in other ways.
And let me give you a
couple of examples.
You can learn to discriminate
between two things.
We've only talked about one
thing so far, bell, food.
But what if you have a black
patch, for example, that
predicts food coming, and a gray
one that predicts it's
not coming, you can distinguish
between those two.
You can get second order
conditioning.
And let me show you that.
The dog learns that the
bell predicts food.
Now, there's no food presented
for a while.
But there's a black patch
presented that you see
presented with the tone.
Because you know the tone
predicts food, the animal
figures, well, maybe this
is a pretty good hint
that food is coming.
And after a while, it begins to
salivate to this one, even
though it was never directly
paired with the food itself.
So it's learning.
It's a transitive inference
that it's making.
If the bell predicts it and the
square goes with the bell,
at some point I'll start
salivating for the square
because that sounds like a
pretty good candidate for
predicting the future.
So that's pretty sophisticated,
too.
You don't even have
food in this part.
But it's even more sophisticated
than that.
So look at these two things.
And you can think about, I'm
going to let you think about
this for a moment.
Here are two groups
of animals.
Or it could be people.
It would work just
the same way.
So here's the conditioned
stimulus and the unconditioned
stimulus, for example, a bell
and the food, the bell and the
food, the bell and the food.
One group only gets
bell, food, bell,
food kinds of pairings.
The other group gets
the same pairings.
But in between, they'll have a
random food reward, two random
bells, a random food,
random bell.
Now, the pairings
are identical.
That's what's shown in orange.
This group will learn better
and faster, more strongly,
than this group.
Even though they've had the
identical number of pairings.
Why will this group
learn more slowly?
Why will, even though they have
an identical number of
times that they got the
tone and the food, the
tone and the food--
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there a little bit
of extinction between--
PROFESSOR: It's an idea that
is an extinction between--
I think that's a good idea.
So that's a very good answer,
the extinction between--
because, when you get this
CS alone, you're
fighting the learning.
But it's telling you the
system is smart, right?
Because what it's kind of doing
is saying, look, eh, CS
alone, not always a reliable
predictor.
So I'll learn it.
But I'm not going to believe
it so strongly, right?
It's basically because you're
sticking extinction in between
those, right?
You're also having some trials
with the food that aren't
predicted either, right?
So it's like the animal or you
are learning what's a really
excellent signal.
And if there's other stuff in
there that gives the signal
not the same predictive power
for the future you learn more
slowly unless certainly
that relationship.
OK?
So that's pretty smart, too.
Here's another way in
which it's smart.
And I'll tell you
the phenomenon.
And you think about why you
think learning might work this
way in animals and people.
So pretend there's a tone that
predicts food just like we've
been talking about all
the way through.
Food stops.
And now you get a tone and a
light, a tone and a light, a
tone and a light.
The tone predicts it's food.
You're getting this
part, again,
without food being presented.
And now you get the
light alone.
OK?
Or everything's the same.
But there isn't the initial
learning with the tone.
And then in the end you're
tested for the lights.
And what happens is there's less
conditioning to the light
here than here, even though
you've seen a light an exact
even number of times.
Why is the conditioning to
the light weaker here?
Why is it weaker
here than here?
This is an information problem
for the brain to solve about
the truth of the world.
Well, our interpretation
is this.
Tone, food, tone, food, you
go, good, I got it.
Easy, right?
Now you get tone and light
together for a while.
And you go, OK, I know the
tone is really important.
The light, I don't know.
The tone was perfectly good.
The light seems redundant,
informationally redundant.
So now when it's a light alone,
you don't have so much
conditioning.
Because you didn't care about
the light so much.
The food had all the information
you needed.
The light was informationally
redundant, right?
It was superfluous.
Here you only got trained with
the tone and the lights.
So you never made a bet on
what's the critical thing.
They both predicted evenly.
So when the light comes by
itself, that was always
something that seemed like a
pretty good signal equally
good to the tone.
So that's very sophisticated
that the animal learning it or
the human learning it is
deciding what's the
information that's diagnostic
and what's the information
that's redundant.
And it's conditioning
across that, right?
So it's not just very
simple reflexes.
It's sophisticated learning.
So now I'm going to
switch gears.
So we're going to have a
demonstration that involves
the opposite of fearful things
like spraying water and
popping balloons.
But I can't tell you too
much about this.
But I can tell you it'll
be pretty pleasant.
But I need somebody who's
willing to step out of the
room for a moment to do this.
OK, thanks.
Yeah, yeah, you can safely
take off your jacket now.
And what's your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Sam.
PROFESSOR: Sam, OK.
Try not to listen
if possible, OK?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So you guys are
going to help me perform
instrumental conditioning.
And then we'll discuss
what that is.
Our job is to have Sam come over
here and pick this up.
OK?
Your job, as Sam comes in for
every action he takes, a step
this way, you played this game
as a kid, or an arm going in
the right direction, applaud if
he's doing something that
gets him closer to the goal of
picking up the brain and
withhold your applause if he's
doing something that's taking
him away from that.
Is that OK?
All right, OK.
So we're going to discuss what
instrumental conditioning is.
And then we're going to slightly
think philosophically
about whether this is how you
learn to do everything.
You get to choose who the
applause comes from, your
parents, your family, your
friends, medical schools and
law schools and graduate
schools.
You get to choose who the
applause comes from, about how
much of our lives is responding
to the applause
that we care about.
So we'll start more simply,
less philosophically.
Let's think about this.
The examples we talked so far in
classical conditioning all
build on what feels like a basic
reflex, salivating for
food, flinching for
water, right?
So if we ask somebody, why do
you work hard, there's not to
be very good explanation in
terms of those initial
reflexes, right?
You're not flinching.
You're not looking for
food or water.
And yet much of our life is
involved in endeavors that we
learn where there's no primary
reflex that we
can see in the story.
And so operant or instrumental
conditioning, those two words
are interchangeable, is the way
that psychologists have
tried to understand those
forms of learning.
And it began something
like this.
And this is from Thorndike.
He put a cat into
a puzzle box.
I'll show you what the box looks
like or a sketch of it.
The cat had to unlatch a door
by pulling a latch.
So here's, the cat's
in a box like this.
To get out, which cat wants to
get out, he or she has to push
this, which will
push the latch.
Now, that's not obvious
to a cat.
It wouldn't be necessarily
obvious to a person but
definitely not obvious
to a cat.
And the animal learned it by
trial and error sort of like
Sam did, right?
And where is the unconditioned
stimulus?
There's no salivation or
any reward like that.
So Thorndike proposed that
people and animals learn
things by the consequence
of their response.
And the Law of Effect says the
consequence of a response
determines whether it is
strengthened or weakened.
You can be rewarded.
That will strengthen
a response.
You can have no reward.
That will weaken it.
You can be punished.
That will greatly weaken
the response.
So here's the cat.
Here's an example of a cat.
At first, it takes a long time
for the cat to get out of
there as it tries different
things.
But over repeated trials,
the cat can get out
really, really fast.
And how Thorndike, by
observation and thinking,
thought about it was at the
beginning the animal
wants to get out.
It has no idea how
it gets out.
So it does everything it can.
It scratches at the bars.
It pushes at the ceiling.
It digs through the floor.
It howls.
And at some moment, it
presses a lever.
And that's good, right?
So here's different things the
animal starts with thinking
might be good ideas.
But because it discovers with
repeated efforts, repeated
trials, that pressing the lever
works, these get weakened.
This gets strengthened.
So the consequence of a response
determines whether
it's strengthened or weakened.
And now there's no salivating
or reflex or
anything like that.
You can learn then
almost anything.
So this was picked up
a lot in the US.
John Watson is a famous name.
You'll see kind of a haunting
film of him performing this
kinds of stuff with infants in
a kind of a way that we would
never allow ethically now.
It's not horrible.
But it's pretty bad.
But it's a famous thing.
And you'll just get a feeling
of the power of this.
Behaviorism, that if you study
behavior, instead of going for
things like unobservable
thoughts, that you would just
do observable actions.
And you wouldn't make inferences
about the mind that
you can't measure.
You make a stimulus.
You measure the response.
And that's it.
No fundamental differences
between animals and humans,
and you make laws that describe
the relationships
between stimulating the
environment and physical
behaviors that you can observe
or responses out in the world
that an organism has.
So I'll come back to
this a little bit.
But one of the ways he wanted
to show that anybody could
learn anything, because right
now, don't forget, the way we
set this up, anybody
can learn anything.
You can applaud anything,
right?
So you can teach anybody
anything by this perspective.
And he wanted to show that
he could teach an infant
initially, whose name
was Little Albert.
That was his cover name.
Nobody actually knows his real
name or what happened to him.
Well, nothing horrible happened
to this person we
know about.
And now you would never do
an experiment like this.
You have this in your notes.
This is a long version of the
movies taken of this actual
sort of experiment that
we wouldn't do now.
And I'll show you a short
version in a couple minutes
where he got an infant to become
afraid of a rabbit that
the infant previously
was not afraid of.
And then the other huge name
in this is B.F. Skinner who
worked at Harvard, consequence
of a response, again, creates
the responses that we
make in the world.
And his sense response is not
just the laboratory one but
things we do in the world with
each other and to each other.
And so the classical
conditioning, the
CS elicits the CR.
The conditioned stimulus, the
bell, elicits the conditioned
response, salivation.
But in instrumental conditioning
CRs are omitted.
And you can do really anything
that's in the range of what an
organism can do.
And then he could show kind of
impressively how you might
imagine a chain of these
things would
lead to complex behaviors.
So he would teach pigeons and
other animals to first to
click to get a pellet, then
where to click it, then to
where to face before
you click it.
And he would just keep adding
little pieces, shape the
pieces up from the first step
to the second step, until he
got pretty complex behaviors.
OK, so now I'm going to show a
slightly longer clip that has
in it these kinds of experiments
and Little Albert.
It's kind of cool because in the
sense that we can actually
see films of these sort of
historical things, which often
we don't get to do in various
science fields.
So let's talk about that
for just one moment.
So we can talk about primary
reinforcers like food, thrist,
or pain, things that go with
life, right, pain, not being
injured, food, and thirst.
We can talk about secondary
reinforcers that we know a lot
about, money, attention of
other people, praise from
other people, admissions to
places you want to be admitted
to, promotions when you
want to get them.
There can be positive
or negative rewards.
And I'm going talk
about one thing.
But just for a moment the
behaviorists said anybody can
learn anything, right?
We'll come back to that.
So that's been a big debate
whether anything can be
equally learned with
any other thing.
And the other thing that's
striking is B.F. Skinner
particularly said that we have
an illusion of free will, that
all we are, are learning
these things.
And we might as well get over
our illusion of free will.
Scientifically, it's very hard
for even the best scientific
psychologists to tell
you whether free
will exists or not.
That's not something that's
easy for us to begin to
imagine how to measure.
These kinds of learning
things are very
impressive in many ways.
And we'll talk about
some of that.
So let me talk to you about one
way in which, for example,
casinos get people to come back
often and other things in
life, without giving you
money every time.
Because then they wouldn't
make money, right?
So your book talks about a
number of examples of this.
But I'll just pick one,
partial reinforcement.
So this means when do you get,
in these animals, when do you
get a reward?
Every time or only
1/3 of the time?
So of course, you learn faster
if you get a reward every time
than if it's 1/3 of the time.
You're not quite as impressed
and excited.
But here's the interesting
thing.
If you stop giving the reward,
these animals will go on for
quite a while before
they extinguish.
These animals will extinguish
right away and stop
responding.
Why will these animals keep
behaving for a time, even
though you've entirely
stopped the rewards?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Since they only got it
30% of the time anyway, it
seems plausible to them that
it would go a couple more
times without them getting it.
PROFESSOR: Yes, since they
only got, the answer was,
which was right, they only got
it 30% of the time, so the
first one or two nonpayments,
right, they're going to go,
well, it's coming up next, OK,
in a couple more, OK, I'm
coming up soon until they
finally decide that the whole
thing is over, right?
So that's very interesting, the
different reinforcement
schedules, how they relate.
You might think, well, you
always learn better if you
reward more.
But in some cases, if you want
to get people to keep doing
stuff without direct reward,
partial reinforcement is
actually more powerful.
Now we're going to move into
dog experiments and then
directly to sort of
thinking about
people and our own lives.
So this is a famous, famous
experiment at the University
of Pennsylvania from Seligman.
In this case, he used dogs.
It's been done with many species
in many circumstances.
And he put them in a hammock.
So there's two dogs on two sides
of a thing that they
walked around.
And they don't see each other.
The dog, A, would periodically
get a shock.
And it could stop the shock by
pushing a panel near its nose.
As soon as the shock came,
it could turn its nose
and stop the shock.
Dog B on the other side of the
divider would get exactly the
same shock.
It would stop at exactly the
moment that the first dog
stopped it.
But dog B had no direct control,
equal number of
shocks, equal duration of
objective pain, if you want to
call it that way.
One animal has the capacity
to stop it.
The other does not.
So that's the first part
of the experiment.
And the second part of the
experiment they're put into a
shuttle box.
It's just a box with a big
divider in the middle.
And they're just hanging
out there.
And then they hear a tone.
At first, it means
nothing to them.
And then comes a shock on
the grid on the floor.
And at first, they don't
know what to do.
But then after a while, they
get smart like the cat.
And they jump over the divider
to the other side.
And it's all OK.
So you can imagine that when
they hear the tone pretty
quickly that what do
they learn to do?
Jump over the divider
and stop the pain.
And here's the remarkable
thing.
For the animals who had the
experience that pushing the
panel stopped the pain, they
learned that pretty quickly.
For the animals who could not
stop the pain initially, they
don't learn how to escape
when they could.
It's as if the animals in group
B, what they learned
about life, it's painful.
And you can't do anything
about it.
The animals in group A
learned pain happens.
But I can do something
about it.
So here's the animal.
At first, it doesn't
know what to do.
It's getting the shock.
But with trials, the animal
learns to jump and jump so
quickly that it doesn't have
almost any problem.
Here's a tone, boom.
It's out of there.
It learns to avoid the pain.
But what happens to the animals
who either had the
escapable shock or the ones?
The ones who could poke their
nose, they also learned this.
The ones who could jump over,
there's nothing preventing
them from learning that.
They just don't escape.
It's what Seligman called
learned helplessness, that the
animals learn, from the first
experience, their conclusion
was pain happens.
And I can't do anything
about it.
And then when they get in a
second situation where they
can do a lot about it, they
continue to feel helpless and
not do something about it.
It's like a deep lesson about
life, like when do you think
you can make your situation
better and when do you think
there's nothing I
can do about it?
It's just bad, bad, bad.
So there's ideas about that some
of this might be related
to people who struggle with
depression but also other
things in life.
So here's the idea from Seligman
as an explanation of
how we have resilience.
The idea is that we all get in
sometimes in small doses,
sometimes in tragically
large doses, difficult
things into our lives.
How do we explain those
difficulties that have
happened to us, the
setbacks we have?
Do we think they're
internal to us?
I'm the kind of person
who has bad luck.
I'm the kind of person that
these things happen to.
Or is it external?
Somebody gave me a test.
What can I do about that?
But next week the
test is over.
And life will be better.
Is it global or specific?
Does it just seem miserable
all over?
Or is it just one specific
squirt in the face that this
faculty member gave me?
Is it stable or unstable?
Are bad things just seeming
to happen all the time?
Or is it one occasion?
And you can imagine that people
who believe that bad
things are internal,
global, and stable
will learn to be helpless.
Everything seems dark
and hopeless.
People who believe that things
are external, specific, and
unstable think, the next
time I can do better.
I can bounce back from
this and do better.
And it's not only in terms of
the sort of spirit of people
and trying to get people to
bounce back from setbacks.
It's even things like
job applications.
Seligman did the
following bet.
I don't even know what
corresponds to it before.
But there used to be an era when
people would go knock on
doors and try to sell
you insurance.
We don't do that
anymore, right?
Because if somebody comes to our
door, knocks on our door,
we're calling the police.
But when things were more
calm, you'd open
the door and talk.
Or they would give you cold
calls, which you don't get
much more anymore these days.
You guys, have you ever even
heard that phrase?
You'd work at some insurance
company.
And you'd go, here's some random
telephone numbers.
You call them up.
And you try to sell
them insurance.
Usually, you get abused
on the phone.
Or somebody slams the doors.
But these salespeople, they
make commissions.
And they keep going.
And he said, let
me get my test.
He gave a questionnaire whether
people interpret the
world one way or the other way,
the resilient way or the
learned helplessness way.
And you give your usual
interview way for picking
sales people.
And let me see who picks
a better salesperson.
And his questionnaire picked
Because if you have a sales job
where people often kick
you out and hang up on you, you
better be pretty external,
specific, and unstable in your
perception on things, right?
Because when you have 100 people
who hang up on you or
close the door on you for one
sale, you need to have a thick
resilient skin.
So there's lots of ways in which
I think this speaks to
how do we respond to the
setbacks in our lives.
So let me talk about some
limits to conditioning.
And some of these that I think
touch also on what are the
values by which we
lead our lives.
It's not going to be
telling you that.
But it'll make you think about
some of the mechanics of what
matters to you.
So let me slide back
for a moment.
So the behaviorists said
everybody can learn
everything.
Everybody can learn
In that sense, it was seen
as a very democratic and
egalitarian perspective.
Everybody can learn
everything.
It's just how you set up the
contingencies in the
environment.
And then Garcia did a famous
experiment where he had rats
get shocks or receive
lithium chloride,
which made them nauseous.
And they either had a bright
noisy stimulus.
Or they tasted some
sweet water.
And even though these things
were arbitrarily combined, the
rats learned, who received
shocked, learn to fear the
bright noise, the bright
light and the noise.
And the rats who got the lithium
chloride that made
them nauseous learned to
fear the sweet water.
Do you see why?
When we get nauseous, do we
think like, boy, it was noisy
last night?
Or do you think, when you wake
up in the morning and you feel
nauseous, what's the first
thing you think?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, something I
ate, right, we're prepared for
internal nausea to think
about food as a risk.
And if it's a shock, we're
prepared to think of
something out there.
So these animals instinctively,
not on the
basis of the training,
instinctively said, if I feel
a shock, it's probably related
to this bright noisy stimulus
that warns me.
If I feel nauseous, it's related
to the sugar water.
And they had these opposite
patterns of learning for the
stimuli as if these animals
were prepared to fear some
things and not others.
So it wasn't that everything
could be matched with
everything.
And in fact, with humans,
they've done things like show
you pictures either of
snakes and spiders
or flowers and mushrooms.
And then those predicted
a shock, a
small shock to humans.
And they measured your galvanic
skin response and
autonomic response.
When you think you're going to
get a shock, you start to get
a little sweaty.
And what they found was--
and this will not shock you--
they had better conditioning,
you more quickly and completely
learned that a
snake or a spider predicts
a shock than
a flower or a mushroom.
Even though, objectively, they
were just as predictive.
There's something about snakes
and spiders that gets us ready
for scary stuff.
And flowers and mushrooms, they
really have to punish us
before we think they're evil
signals so, again, a human
example of preparedness.
We don't learn everything
equally.
We are prepared to learn some
things and not others.
Same thing with Little Albert,
the child that you saw, that
kind of a film has
a funny status.
And we'll talk about a few
more things this semester
where that experiment,
why should that
experiment not be done?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Nobody knows what
happened to Little Albert.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well, you would
never terrorize a child,
right, to scare the child.
So weirdly enough, though, these
studies remain in the
field because since we
can't do them again.
Because we know they're
not right to do.
We try to learn lessons
from them so
that we learn something.
The rat worked.
He got scared of a rat.
And then he got scared
of a bunny.
He got scared of
a cat, anything
animal, anything furry.
But if they gave him a wooden
block, that didn't work.
It's not everything.
It has to be prepared
from that.
Here's another one that also
challenges simple ideas of do
we always learn simply
to get a reward.
What kind of learning might
exist that's rewardless?
So there's three groups of
rats in a goal maze.
There's food rewards every
day for one group.
They're the happy group.
There's no rewards for
a grumbling group.
There's a third group that gets
no reward for 10 days.
And then it gets reward.
So reward all the time, reward
never, no reward for 10 days
and then you start to get
rewards all the time, and
here's what happens
to the learning.
If you look at this green line,
that's the food that
gets rewarded all the time.
So they make fewer errors
so they can
get to the food faster.
If you look at the group that's
never rewarded, this
yellow line, it's
pretty steady.
It's like I'm hanging out,
no reason to go anywhere.
There's not much going on.
Look at the orange group.
For 10 days, up to here, they
look like the yellow line,
right, not getting rewarded.
I'm just going to
saunter around.
There's nothing interesting
to learn here.
But boom that first day that
it's rewarded, but just one
day of learning, they're
all caught up.
They're all caught up.
So people call this latent
learning, that they were
really learning a lot about
their environment anyway, even
though it was of no
use at the moment.
And then the moment it became
valuable information, boom,
they're all caught up.
It's as if they learned
all this information.
And it was ready to go.
Latent learning, the information
is stored up just
because they were in the
environment, even though it
was unrewarded.
And as we go around, we often
pick up stuff, even though
there's no direct reward.
And sometimes it turns
out to be useful.
People also love, humans,
including infants,
contingency, the idea that
we feel like we have
control over our world.
So here's a two-month-old
infant, very young infant, in
a little experiment where they
put the infant in a crib.
And above is a very colorful
colored mobile.
And in one version, when the
infant moves his or her head,
there's a switch
in the pillow.
The mobile moves.
And the infants are smiling
and cooing.
They love it.
This is awesome.
They move their head.
The thing moves, pretty
impressive for a two-month.
All they can do is wiggle
their head, right?
They're not walking
or anything.
They put another group of
infants in who have no switch.
And just periodically, they
turn on the mobile.
There's no smiling
and no cooing.
And they equate the number
of mobile turnings.
Why is that?
Well, if it's just because you
like the mobile turning, then
you should have both groups be
equaling cooing and smiling or
disinterested.
But there's something
fundamentally rewarding for
humans, even at the age of two,
to feel like they have
control over their environment
and their pleasures.
And that's not explained
by conditioning.
Nobody's getting
anything more.
They're both seeing the equal
number of interesting turns.
But one group feels like they're
controlling their
environment.
Here's another one that I'm
going to show you in an animal
experiment where you
can control things.
But you can imagine
in your own life.
In my life, I see this
all the time.
It's nice when something
pleasant happens in your life
and your situation gets better
in some way, right?
You get a better iPad, right?
But how hard is it emotionally
when something gets worse?
They take all your iPads away
or more serious things.
When things get worse, often
we feel pretty miserable.
And here's a neat
example of that.
So these are rats in an
experiment so everything's
controlled.
So here's one group of rats.
This is how quickly
they're running.
So it's good to be high.
One group of rats is
constantly getting
one pellet a day.
So they learn what to do.
And they're sort of hanging
out here doing well.
A second group of rats is the
luckiest group of all.
They get eight pellets.
And they learn more.
But they flatten out.
So you get more reward.
You drive the behavior more.
That's not unexpected.
The interesting thing are
the two contrast groups.
The contrast groups start
off with one or eight.
And then, after a couple days,
they're flipped around.
So some started with one.
Then they got eight pellets.
Others started with eight.
Then they got one.
Does that make sense?
So here's the contrast
group of eight.
They're learning one.
They go eight, woo.
They're happy.
They're getting eight.
Life got good.
Look at the group for
whom life got worse.
I'm getting eight.
I'm getting one.
It really stinks.
They're actually worse than the
groups that got one all
along, right?
This is the lowest
line of all.
They're protesting.
This stinks.
I was getting eight.
Now I'm getting one.
What a rip off.
What kind of world
do I live in?
So the learning is
protesting that.
Now, by purely conditioning
one, why would
this group be worse?
They're still getting
a pellet.
But because they're interpreting
it as a world
that's going downhill, as a
worsening situation, they're
less prone to learn it.
They're sort of protesting in
their learning, things having
gotten worse in the world.
A really interesting theme along
the line of this reward,
an unbelievable one that has
gotten a lot of attention, is
delayed gratification.
If you think about it, and the
analysis is not purely
scientific but is a theme,
delayed gratification is a
spectacular part of your life,
right, especially if you go
through higher education.
Or maybe everything is
like this, right?
Do a good job in primary thing
and you'll get to a good
middle school.
Do a good job in middle school,
we'll get to a good
high school.
Do a good job in high school,
you get to MIT.
Do a good job at MIT, you go to
med school or law school or
become a teacher, whatever
you want to do.
A good job at that and you'll
get to this thing.
Do a good job of that, finally,
thank you very
much, you're 95.
And you're done.
I mean it's kind of like you
guys are waiting a long time
between the efforts you're
doing and what you might
consider a palpable reward.
So here's a fantastically
interesting study from Walter
Mischel done at Stanford
some years ago.
These children were four
to five years old.
There were about 600
that were studied.
They were mostly the children
of faculty and graduate
students at Stanford.
And they would come
into a room.
And the experiment, slightly
varied, was
basically like this.
They would sit in front
of either a cookie or
marshmallow.
They used different rewards.
But imagine it's
a marshmallow.
In the movie I'll show you,
it's Oreo cookies.
And they were told this.
And they tried to make this,
Walter Mischel who did the
experiment describes how he
played with kids to try to get
the marshmallow look
really awesome.
And the kid would sit there,
the four or five-year-old.
And they were told, I'm going
to leave the room now.
And there's a bell here.
If you really want to eat that
marshmallow, ring the bell and
just eat it.
But if you wait a while--
they didn't tell them
it was 15 minutes.
It was 15 minutes.
I'll come back.
And I'll give you two.
Delayed gratification, I can
have one marshmallow now.
Or if I hang in there for 15
minutes and don't touch it, I
can get two.
Let me tell you the results.
And then let me show
a film of this.
When I was looking on YouTube
and the internet and stuff,
there's a lot of posed
movies out there.
This is the only one I found
from Walter Mischel himself
that's a real movie of real
kids really doing this.
I don't know why all the ones
are posed out there.
But here's something
astounding.
So these are all pretty similar
children, children of faculty.
Children varied how long
they could wait.
And if they took, for example,
the children who
didn't wait very long.
They could only wait
30 seconds until
they ate the cookie.
And they compared them to the
children who would wait for
the full 15 minutes
to eat the cookie.
These are four and
five-year-olds.
When they looked at them at 18
and their SATs, the children
who would wait 15 minutes scored
over 200 points higher,
which you know is a lot.
That was in the days we just
had two SAT tests.
So it was 1,600.
And by many, many measures
in terms of educational
attainment, in terms of health,
and many measures, the
longer you waited at age four
or five, the healthier you
were, the better SAT scores you
were, the further you went
in school, astounding
correlations
with real life stuff.
And people are stunned
by this.
Partly, it's again, who
knows what goes into
that at four or five.
How much is the influence
of parents?
of cultures and genes?
Who knows?
But that fateful moment when
the child goes for the
marshmallow or not correlates
with incredibly important
outcomes in the future.
So let's see.
Here we go.
And you know, right, every
college I remember personally,
it was always a battle,
like am I going
to have fun or study?
Am I going to have
fun or study?
There's so many chances
to have fun.
And there's so many pressures
to study, right?
Well, studying can be fun.
Learning is fun.
How about when rewards harm?
Again, these are things that are
not strictly predicted by
conditioning.
I have three or four
more minutes.
So rats love to run, if you had
a hamster or anything like
that, they love running
wheels.
What if you give them, every
time they run, a food reward?
Then it turns out rats no
longer run for fun.
They only run when the
food is given.
If you start to extinguish,
they stop running.
So what had been a natural thing
that seemed like a whole
lot of fun, if it became the
price you pay for a reward,
all a sudden becomes a chore.
A widely cited experiment
for Mark Lepper, he took
preschoolers, so four-year-old
children, who love to draw.
Lots of preschoolers
love to draw.
Then they started to give
them, every time they
drew, a gold star.
Every time they got a reward.
What happened when they stopped
given the gold stars?
The kids stopped drawing.
This is incredibly often cited
in incredibly interesting
debates about whether children
in impoverished schools should
be given cash rewards
for studying hard.
There's lots of debates about
whether that's a good thing or
not a good thing, an effective
thing or not
an effective thing.
This study is often cited for
arguing, if you make something
that you should love, like
learning, purely rewarded, the
minute the reward stops, it
becomes a complete chore.
But we don't know how
that applies.
Because we might read
about things like
baseball player salaries.
And it seems like there's a
pretty good relationship
between performance
and salary.
So it's not simply that
way in the world.
We know that often rewards
are associated with high
performance and promote
high performance.
It's pretty complicated.
The last slide is about a
fantastic debate that occurred
here in many ways between B.F.
Skinner at Harvard and Noam
Chomsky at MIT, which is, in
what sense is language learned
by conditioning?
So here's an example
against it.
At one month, there's a switch
inside a rubber nipple hooked
to a tape recorder.
And when the baby sucked,
the tape plays.
This allows the baby to
perform, to behave.
And they would play syllables
from different languages.
And they may or may not be
in their own languages.
And by four days, babies
preferred the languages that
they are exposed to.
And one of the questions is,
people said, well, how do we
get kids to learn language
from a behaviorist
perspective?
So one of the things that they
studied children, and they'll
often, young children will say
wrong things like mama isn't a
boy, he a girl.
That's not good grammar,
right?
And so there was an intuition
that parents would then go,
that's not good grammar.
And sometimes parents do that.
But when they did studies
where they recorded long
sessions with parents
doing this, parents
almost never corrected.
It was very rare.
You may feel different
from your own record.
But statistically, it's
very rare to collect.
They often say that's right
or something like that.
So how's the child picking up
language if nobody's giving
them rewards in terms
of whether
they're right or wrong?
The idea is that we can say an
infinite number of sentences.
Well, how can we possibly be
rewarded or conditioned for an
infinite variety of sentences?
How could that work?
And finally, the phenomenon of
overgeneralizing, you may know
that children will
overgeneralize things.
Because we usually end E-D to
make a verb past tense, right?
But some verbs don't
work that way.
So you would say, my teacher
held the rabbit.
Children often make these
overgeneralized rules.
They say, my teacher
holded the rabbit.
So obviously, they're learning a
rule and then applying it to
an instance that they
never hear.
Because almost no
adult says that.
So they must be producing that,
not on the basis of
conditioning, but Chomsky argued
on the basis of sort of
genetically prepotent ways in
which we learn language, rules
that we develop and figure out
language in the world.
I will say that, for those of
you happen to be interested in
this topic, there's been a
striking pushback on that in
what people call statistical
learning.
So as much as this seemed like
a done deal 10 years ago, it
turns out the truth might be
somewhere in the middle with
some genetic prepotentiziation
but also a lot of learning
from your environment both.
So you can think, as you leave
here, what are the applause
that you listen to?
Where's your free will and your
choice of what goals you
pursue and what matters
to you?
And how does the world attempt
to teach you things that you
learn about what you
want to do and why
you want to do them?